mio ingrediente segreto
[Musica]
[Risate]
siamo tornati a scuola sono sempre io la
vostra maestra Ciao rossa
e quest'anno sarò più cattiva che mai
avete fatto i compiti per le vacanze
perché se no le borse ossa
[Applauso]
mio figlio Fatima faticoso
Infatti E allora
preparati
Ma tu Merlino li hai fatti peggio per
voi
un tramonto in questo mondo
Ah sì E allora adesso vi interrogo e
vediamo se avete studiato
non ho nemmeno fatto i compiti per le
vacanze figurati
[Musica]
e adesso faremo un'interazione con un
argomento a vostra scelta ci sarà da
divertirsi
un argomento a scelta io ho una cosa
bellissima di cui parlarvi una novità
incredibile ma ve la dirò dopo quando
sarà il mio turno voi nel frattempo
cliccate mi piace qua sotto perché se
questo video raggiunge i 6000 mi piace
ci sarà un altro episodio con la maestra
cattiva
posso preparare qualcosa da mangiare
Mi raccomando ho scelto Ma io non ho
studiato niente però
beh io posso fare i miei scherzetti
punto finto
questo è una scoreggia
ah Oggi farò tanti cacca
il telecomando della cacca telecomandata
[Musica]
come ho fatto malissimo
Vitale viene la lavagna e dimmi qual è
il tuo argomento a scelta
Allora io come dimostrazione ho portato
Eh il mio pentolino e io farò una zuppa
di legumi e verdure e ti pare che Vitale
non porta qualcosa che riguarda il cibo
come sempre Scommetto che dopo la vorrà
pure mangiare
ci stai
mettendo il tempo
per preparare le cose ci vuole un po' di
tempo no E come fanno a cuocersi se no
Ma cosa cavolo c'entra la
zuppa non c'è neanche la cucina
ora tu
Devo cuocerlo meglio
[Musica]
Così impari a non aver studiato e poi la
zuppa non c'entra nulla a scuola
va bene maestro Ho capito però almeno
posso finire di fare la zuppa Sì ok però
dirò solo 10 secondi è arrivato di
entrare in azione manca il mio
ingrediente segreto
10 9 8
5 12
basta hai finito finito
[Musica]
il tempo Adesso è l'ora di assaggiarla
Non vedo l'ora è la mia parte preferita
assaggiare le cose da mangiare
cosa che schifo la cacca dentro la stufa
Come ti sei permesso cos'è me la volevi
far mangiare come la cacca ma non sono
stato io sono sicura che questo è uno
scherzo di Billy Non è possibile che
Vitale ha fatto una zuppa del genere
[Musica]
io non c'entro niente Io questa zuppa
non l'assaggio l'assaggio tu no no io
questa zuppa non l'assaggio non
l'assaggio No no non sono stato io a
metterla la cacca
no no no no no
Che puzza che schifo
[Musica]
e Adesso tocca ad Anita Anita vieni alla
lavagna ho una novità importantissima da
darvi la novità importantissima è che ha
appena uscito in preordine il mio
nuovissimo libro La città stregata gli
investigatori del mistero leggendo
questo libro vi trasformerete in dei
veri investigatori del mistero come noi
infatti c'è proprio un mistero da
risolvere e poi riuscirete a risolvere
il mistero prima di arrivare alla fine
del libro Mi raccomando preordinatelo
subito perché con il preordine
Riceverete anche una sorpresa
No il nuovo libro di Anita Stories
dammelo dammelo
una cosa te lo presto così puoi leggerlo
Ok va bene però trattelo bene perché è
un libro speciale che potrebbe avere
anche dei poteri nascosti Wow non vedo
l'ora di scoprire l'alfabeto segreto
preordinatela anche voi Così scopriremo
il mistero tutti insieme È bellissimo il
nuovo libro di Anita e poi in copertina
ci sono anch'io modestamente infatti
Nella storia ci sono anch'io e farò
anche tante cose simpatiche oltre a
mangiare ovviamente preordinatelo subito
per scoprire tutte le cose che combino
nella storia il nuovo libro
regali segreti una storia vincente al
Vabbè Il tuo segreto no deve essere mio
devo rubarlo subito come posso fare
Ah ah ah
niente ma questa può essere l'occasione
per rubare il libro
hai studiato vero Almeno questa volta
che tu non studi mai
certo che ho studiato ho studiato
matematicamente il libro di inglese ah
ah ah ah
cosa stai facendo niente volevo vedere
la copertina è così bello Posso
guardarla la copertina ah ah
pronti a guardare a toccare il libro di
Anita Ah va bene complimenti
e la maestra io non ho studiato questa
vacanza sono andato in giro a fare i
miei scherzetti però posso parlare di
una cosa che so benissimo e cioè degli
scherzetti per esempio guarda questo
Guarda guarda una vita
una vita
Ma che schifo Scusami che schifo Billy e
poi un'altra guardia Oh sembra un
megafono piccolino ma in realtà
[Musica]
cosa
Billy Come ti sei permesso
faccio anche un dito o un dito finto
maestra
per favore maestra lo può prendere
[Musica]
maestra sì
Ma questa cosa Sì sì ancora ancora
Questa sì che è una puzza incredibile
Queste sono le tue scorregge quando tu
sei addormentato
[Applauso]
come hai iniziato a fare questi scherzi
e ora bastati
Che cos'è questo
e ora è quello che ti metti se il re
della cacca dovrai tenere sempre questo
cappello Vai a posto Uffa Che cos'è No
il cappello di cacca va bene Io vado a
posto
Billy Che cos'è dietro la schiena
no non ho niente è solo la mia
[Musica]
puzzolente c'ho solo il mio testo
puzzolente lo metto qui va bene non ho
nient'altro
passiamo alla prossima Challenge
[Musica]
seconda Challenge sarà la Challenge
invece dell'inglese sarà dello spagnolo
Vediamo se avete studiato lo spagnolo
Vitale Vieni alla lavagna e la
professoressa
Tra l'altro Vitale Disegna il
significato di questa parola
non sono sicurissimo però penso di avere
azzeccato il significato di questa
parola che in realtà viene da due
desinenze cara e Call e praticamente è
la culla dello Slime Ma cosa stai
dicendo che tale però quello È
facilissimo ma ha sbagliato Chissà quale
sarà la sua punizione
è praticamente la colla dello Slime però
è cara quindi è cara con un po' costosa
e Caracol Hai indovinato
No significa lumaca
Ma io non lo sapevo Questa è la tua
punizione per non aver studiato spagnolo
che schifo ce l'ho qui sulla fronte Ma
lo devo tenere tutto il tempo qui Sì sì
proprio così oh oh che schifo normale
fronte
Ok va bene vado a posto con la lumaca
sono riuscito a rubare il libro e lo
leggerò prima di tutti
Sbrigatevi ordinarlo perché sennò io mi
leggerò la fine e ve la rivelerò
rovinandovi il finale perché non avete
letto
Quindi fate in fretta e preordinatelo
Anita la lavagna Eccomi maestra
disegna pelota
io sono più brava in inglese non in
spagnolo forse è Pelota Forse ho capito
Pelota vuol dire
pelata c'è una persona che non ha i
capelli Pelota Giusto No
pilota vuol dire palla No ho sbagliato
e ora che cosa mi farò questa è la tua
posizione ahia
[Musica]
Sì
ma è troppo facile
è il
[Applauso]
[Musica]
il mio libro
lo aveva rubato Billy
maestro Bigli aveva rubato il libro oh
stai scherzando Io avevo detto quando è
prezioso il libro e lui l'ha rubato no
stai scherzando
[Musica]
[Applauso]
Non lo so perché ero lì fermo Luca
adesso io è stato tentato che abbiamo
fatto uno scherzo con me
tu andrai in quella prigione
basta hai rotto le palle Ciccione ma non
mi sento bene
bravi a rubare il libro
digli ha ricevuto quello che si meritava
e noi abbiamo salvato il nostro libro mi
raccomando
Ciao